INTERFERENCE, THAT IS THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE" PAY LAST
NIGHT, WE EXPOSE DEMOCRATS
GROWING DESTRUCTIVE DEMOCRACY,
ESPECIALLY VOTERS IN RED STATE
AMERICA.
LIBERALS VIEW THEM WITH TOTAL
AND UTTER CONTEMPT.
SOCIALISM IS A HARD SELL IN
FLYOVER COUNTRY.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
ELIZABETH WARREN CHOKED EVERY
TIME SHE IS ASKED WHETHER
MEDICARE FOR ALL WILL RAISE
TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
BECAUSE SHE KNOWS IT WILL.
>> DIRECT QUESTION: WILL
MIDDLE-CLASS TAXES GO UP TO PAY
FOR THE PROGRAM?
>> LOOK, WHAT FAMILIES HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IS COST.
TOTAL COST.
>> HOW ARE YOU GOING TO PAY FOR
IT?
ARE YOU GOING TO RAISE
MIDDLE-CLASS TAXES?
>> COSTS ARE GOING TO GO UP FOR
THE WEALTHIEST AMERICANS, FOR
BIG CORPORATE
BIG CORPORATIONS.
AND HARDWORKING, MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO SEE THEIR
COSTS GO DOWN.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS KNOW THEIR
POLICIES ARE NOT GOING TO LEAD
TO A STRONGER ECONOMY.
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO BE
STRONGER THAN TRUMP'S.
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER TRYING TO
MAKE THAT CASE ANYMORE.
INSTEAD, THEY FIND THEMSELVES
REVERTING TO THE OLD
HILLARY CLINTON PLAYBOOK.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU AREN'T
CONFIDENT YOU CAN WIN ON THE
MERITS, UNDERMINE THE PROCESS.
IF YOU LOSE, DON'T ACCEPT THE
OUTCOME AS LEGITIMATE.
WORK TO UNDERMINE ITS LEGITIMACY
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
THERE WERE FOUR KEY FACTS THAT
DEMOCRATS
DEMONSATS
DEMONSTRS
DEMONSTRATE HOW THE DEMOCRATS
USED FOR IN POLLARD'S
USED FOR IN POWLARD'S
USED FOR IN POWERRD'S
USED FOR IN POWERS,'S
USED FOR IN POWERS, DEEP STATE
ACTORS TO TAMPER WITH THE
ELECTION OF 2016, AND THEY'RE
NOT FINISHED YET.
FACT NUMBER ONE: IN APRIL OF
2016, IT WAS THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC THAT HIRED
FUSION GPS, WHICH FUNDED THE
RESEARCH IN THAT PHONY DOSSIER.
THEY RELIED ON A BRITISH SPY, A
FOREIGN AGENT,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, TO COMPILE
WHAT THEY CONSIDERED TO DAMAGING
INFORMATION ON DONALD TRUMP AT
HIS CAMPAIGN.
MUCH OF IT, OF COURSE,
UNVERIFIED AND ULTIMATELY
DISCREDITED.
BUT THAT DIDN'T MATTER TO THEM!
>> CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S BLOSSOMD
>> CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S BLOSSOMS
>> CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S BLOSSOMI
>> CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S BLOSSOMR
SAYS HE WAS INVOLVED WITH
RUSSIANS AND THE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE EFFORT TO COVER IT
UP.
>> GO BACK TO THE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE DOSSIER.
HOW WAS RUSSIA REPORTEDLY TRYING
TO COMPROMISE AND CULTIVATE
DONALD TRUMP FOR YEARS?
BY OFFERING HIM LUCRATIVE
REAL ESTATE DEALS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE TAPE
EXIST WHICH IS BROUGHT UP IN THE
STEELE DOSSIER, WHICH IS, BY THE
WAY, LOOKING BETTER AND BETTER.
>> Laura: THEY PASS THE
ALLEGATIONS TO ANTI-TRUMP
INTEREST IN THE GOVERNMENT, FROM
JOHN McCAIN TO THE FBI.
AND SOUGHT TO OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION OF ANY AND ALL
FIGURES NEAR CANDIDATE TRUMP.
WHAT DID SOMEONE WANTS CALL IT?
AN INSURANCE POLICY, THAT'S
RIGHT.
FACT NUMBER TWO: THE DEMOCRATS
USED THE FBI AND THE OBAMA DOJ
TO PEDDLE THE FOREIGN SOURCE
DOSSIER TO THE FISA COURT TO
SECURE WARRANTS AGAINST TRUMP'S
ADVISORS, LIKE CARTER PAGE BEARD
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY,
DEPUTY ANDREW MCCABE, TRIPPED OE
DEPUTY ANDREW MCCABE, TRIPPED OR
THEMSELVES RUNNING
TO THE FISA COURT THAT
ULTIMATELY PERMITTED THEM TO
SURVEIL AMERICA'S CITIZENS.
AND THEN THE SAME DEEP STATE
ACTORS STARTED LEAKING INFO TO
FRIENDLY MEDIA.
>> WE HAVE HAD REPORTING IN
RECENT MONTHS THAT GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS WAS INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO SET UP MEETINGS WITH
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS,
INCLUDING VLADIMIR PUTIN, FOR
CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP.
WE KNOW CARTER PAGE WAS
CONSIDERED BY THE FBI TO BE
POTENTIALLY A KNOWING RUSSIAN
AGENT, YOU CAN SEE WHY THE
MUELLER INQUIRY MIGHT LOOK FOR
COMMUNICATIONS RELATED TO THEM.
>> Laura: O.
FAX NUMBER THREE: DEMOCRATS USED
FOREIGN AGENTS TO DO THEIR DIRTY
WORK IN 2016.
DO YOU REMEMBER HOW GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, A LOW LEVEL TRUMP
VOLUNTEER, GOT ROPED INTO THIS
ENTIRE DRAMA?
IN APRIL OF 2016, HE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THIS MAN, JUST
SUBMISSIVENESS, A PROFESSOR FROM
MALTA WITH LONG STANDING
TIES TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT FOR
THIS PROFESSOR TRIED TO TEMPT
PAPADOPOULOS, CLAIMING THE
RUSSIANS HAD DIRT ON HILLARY.
WELL, NOT EXACTLY A POLITICAL
CERTIFICATE, SYCOPHANT,
PAPADOPOULOS REPEATED THE INFORA
PAPADOPOULOS REPEATED THE INFORI
PAPADOPOULOS REPEATED THE INFORN
PAPADOPOULOS REPEATED THE INFORT
PAPADOPOULOS REPEATED THE INFORO
ALEXANDER DOWNER.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
MEETING WITH DOWNER WAS SET UP
BY PEOPLE PAPADOPOULOS DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW.
PAPADOPOULOS LATER ACCUSED
DOWNER OF RECORDING THEIR
CONVERSATIONS, HOW CONVENIENT.
AND SOMEHOW, THE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS MADE THEIR WAY TO
THE DEEP STATE CHANNELS AND
BECAME THE PREDICATE FOR THE
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION INTO TEAM
TRUMP.
AND IT ALL HAPPENED COURTESY OF
TWO FOREIGN ACTORS, AND OZZY AND
A MULTI'S, NOT TALKING ABOUT A
CUTE PUPPY.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE TELLING US
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT FOREIGN
INTRUSION IN ELECTIONS?
FACT NUMBER FOUR: WHEN THE
MUELLER PROBE FIZZLED, DEMOCRATS
NEEDED A BACKUP, AND QUICK, AND
THEY THOUGHT THEY FOUND IT.
DEMOCRATS PRAYED AND HOPED THAT
ROBERT MUELLER WOULD UNEARTH
SOMETHING, ANYTHING, TO JUSTIFY
THE IMPEACHMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
WELL, BASICALLY FOUND NOTHING.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, FAR FROM
BREATHING LIFE INTO THE REPORT,
HE KIND OF SUCKED THE LIFE OUT
OF THE REPORT.
>> I WAS STRUCK BY THE ENORMOUS
PERSONAL CONTRAST BETWEEN
ROBERT MUELLER AND DONALD TRUMP.
>> I THINK HE IS OUT OF LEGAL
JEOPARDY, I HATE TO SAY IT.
AND YOU'RE PUTTING MY BLOOD
VESSELS AT RISK, BUT MY HUNCH IS
HE HAS GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT.
>> Laura: WHICH BRINGS US TO
THE PRESENT.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
ACTIVELY INVESTIGATING THE
DEEP STATE MACHINATIONS IN 2016
AND THE ROLE PLAYED BY THE
FOREIGN ACTORS WE JUST TOLD YOU
ABOUT.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO DESTROY
NOT ONLY THE PRESIDENT, BUT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR, AND
A STATE DEPARTMENT ON THE BRINK
OF UNCOVERING THEIR ELECTION
TAMPERING.
>> I THOUGHT POMPEO WAS JUST AN
AMBITIOUS GUY.
AND I'M FINDING OUT HE, LIKE
WILLIAM BARR, ARE TRUMPIAN.
>> BILL BARR, I DON'T WANT TO
SOUND SASSY, BUT GLOBE-TROTTING
ON AN ISSUE THAT IS PERSONAL TO
THE PRESIDENT, DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THE JOB FUNCTION OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT SEEMS
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, SOMEONE FROM
TRUMP'S 2020 REELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
>> BINGO.
>> Laura: WITH THE MEDIA IS
MISSING IN THE MUCH DISCUSSED CL
MISSING IN THE MUCH DISCUSSED CW
MISSING IN THE MUCH DISCUSSED CT
MISSING IN THE MUCH DISCUSSED CH
MISSING IN THE MUCH DISCUSSED CE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT IS THAT
TRUMP REQUESTED UKRAINE'S
COOPERATION TO INVESTIGATE NOT
ONLY WRONGDOING BY THE BIDENS,
BUT THE ENTIRE DEEP STATE, AS
WELL.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE IS WORKING --
THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING -- TO
UNCOVER ELECTION MEDDLING.
I THOUGHT THAT IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANTED.
JUST TODAY, "THE DAILY BEAST"
REPORTS THAT BARR TRAVELED TO
ROME TO LISTEN TO A SECRET
RECORDING OF A DEPOSITION BY THE
PROFESSOR.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS CLEARLY
CLOSING IN ON THE FOREIGN
PLAYERS FROM 2016.
COME ON, THIS ALL EXPLAINS WHY
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FREAKING OUT,
AND THEY ARE SO DETERMINED TO
STOP TRUMP AND SMEAR BARR.
THEY BET THAT IT IS SAFER TO
SULLY TRUMP WITH BOGUS
ACCUSATIONS AND FINALLY FACE THE
MUSIC THEMSELVES.
A TRUE INVESTIGATION OF THEIR
ACTIONS TO INTERFERE IN A